relatively busy afternoon but that's
okay
we are happy
so
chris
you said you had a couple amendments i
do rip some of them burger i have one in
your name and one rip some turcottes
named for senate bill 409 okay pass them
uh madam chair yeah
can i ask a question before we uh deal
with your amendments any question you
want okay
over the weekend i read these bills i
read the amendments i read the testimony
from the hearings and after this
morning's hearing i was much more
confused than i was before oh you think
yeah so
on 409
the active language here is the governor
declares a state of emergency and the
municipality
um
has applied for assistance
the governor with the approval of the
executive council may approve a
non-interest loan
up to the amount of assistance from fema
funds not otherwise appropriated
so that's
that's 409
in 402
the languages
the governor declares a state of
emergency and municipality has applied
then the governor with the approval of
the fiscal committee and the executive
council
may approve disbursements
of financial assistance to the
municipalities
okay so
what is
what is what with both of these are
no not quite one has a non-interest loan
which
we consider a grant i guess
or whatever it's a non it says
non-interest loan
and 402 is just a disbursement of
general fonts apparently
yes
afterwards
kicked in right okay
wait is this language straightforward
enough that
that it
it does what the intended intent was
well
yes i think
the language is
clear
or do we need them both
oh yeah and my question is
do we need them both
she just no that's i don't think i don't
i
from my perspective it's going to be one
so
okay we have two amendments here
yeah to 409.
and um
representative turcott why don't you
tell us what you've done
sure um in the original hearing i just
had some questions on uh
when it talked about anticipated
assistance and i wanted a little more
clarity on on that so um
mickey drew drew up this so it would
instead of saying that it would say
uh anticipate anticipated assistance
from fema and then the changes as agreed
upon by the division of homeland
security emergency management and the
municipality which is what i was going
for
okay so that that just
yeah that was already there
yeah
okay
and then what my amendment does
is says that uh
you have to apply for uh hazard
mitigation grant funding in other words
i'm if you know we've heard the horror
stories down along uh
the gulf coast where
flood after flood after flood and nobody
does anything to mitigate it so that was
that was what what this one
now when i s
when we left on whenever our last
we basically had no disagreement with
bill
okay
so that takes
are they going to have to um we're not
is it going to be both
um executive council and
and um
and and fiscal or one or just
this one just is just one of them i
guess
approval of the executive council
that's two cuts
it's just the executive yeah it doesn't
it doesn't need the bill as it stands
says
gen uh executive fiscal fiscal committee
and executive council
where do you see that
that's what's in the bill now
in line seven
well that's 402. yeah
that's 402. 409 doesn't
it's just because it's a disaster it
doesn't come to fiscal
okay 409 just has executive council
thank you
okay
i mean we'll go back and
once we figure out what we're going to
do we'll
go back and
so jennifer would you two like to just
uh i don't know if we have any more
questions that we need to ask but
sure
vanessa now don't you go and have a baby
oh
oh okay good good
i probably shouldn't have said that this
is
okay yep that's all right we're having
fun and that's
and that's what uh that's what that's
what division two is all about
so are you talking about 402 right now
yeah we're only 409. we're not going to
talk about burning back because
yeah
unless unless you have something you
want to say
about 409 that's going to change my mind
all right so
representative turcotte's amendment
totally
weren't
on board with that
okay
but just your amendment just a couple of
things um
about it
um
do you want to do you want to take a
stab at it we've already kind of talked
about it so we're not the expert
okay just let you know a couple of
things
if there are a couple of things wrong i
want mickey to get it right yeah how's
um okay so yes we took a look at this
amendment this morning and um in looking
at it there
might be some so the goal i think is
well understood um it's the goal is to
promote hazard mitigation funding
and for our agency in particular you
know we are aware of the hazard
mitigation assistance funding grant
programs and that includes things like
pdm uh brick hazard mitigation grant
program things you might have heard of
in the past right um that being said the
way the language is currently written
where it says
shall apply to all available hazard
mitigation grant funding opportunities
there might be funding opportunities
that exist outside of what our agency
tracks and administers that we will not
be able to confirm
and so i bring that up in part as well
knowing that there is a potential
penalty for not meeting that requirement
um
so what you're saying
is you would eliminate it to all
available and maybe progress shall apply
for
well that was my first question
do
i'm going to use the word we we want the
word shall versus should
okay
yeah what line are we on
line four line four so shall is a
mandate so
oh you know why i can't find this it's
because i'm reading your amendment as
opposed to
not like
[Laughter]
so okay okay so where it says the
municipalities shall apply to all
available hazard mitigation grant
funding available to reduce the impact
of a disaster reoccurrence so let's stop
there and just kind of dissect this
first sentence
our question was
shall
the second part was
all available hazard mitigation grant
funding we only know what we
what we know
administer at hsem okay we don't know if
there are other programs in other places
so what we're saying in municipalities
shall apply for
all
hazard mitigation grants
funding from fema
dance
hazard mitigation grant funding
available
this this um this seems to be going off
on a different direction
almost a penalty for not doing it it is
a penalty for not doing it tom that's
the point
well it's it's not it's i mean it's not
the intent of the build it's to
but
the set the intent of the bill is to is
to provide money to the communities
however
if next
year
they have another flood event
and they haven't
done anything to mitigate the flood
danger then they should not be able to
get the money
that's that's what what this mitigation
is all about
okay so why don't we just put put your
amendment on onto 409 and
and cause i'm not sure i'm ready for
409. um both of these bills say
amendment to 409 by the way
no
we're on 409. yeah
yeah jennifer just just give us the
language you want us to use please
okay
we can give you some suggested language
for that first sentence about that but i
guess we need to talk about the second
sentence where it talks about the
penalty
um
do you want to take a stab at that
please sure
um
so i think um i know my primary question
was similar to um yours rep bucco did i
pronounce your last name correctly yes
thank you
um
stating you know what was the what was
the intent of this bill um and so in
diving into that and also looking at
what this requirement might put in place
for municipalities is keeping in mind
that
there are a lot of
potential impacts of requiring something
like this from a community so when they
submit an application to fema for hazard
mitigation assistance programs they're
often required to
do a com you know a complete application
and this often requires engineering um
and additional i wrote some stuff down
additional studies um on the technical
feasibility of multiple different
potential
outcomes in different projects because
fema will often not just accept one idea
they want to see multiple in order to
choose the best one putting it in simple
terms so
there might be um a monetary
you know cost associated with a
community applying to hma and we wanted
to make you all aware of that as part of
this okay can i do that
yes you may is there a is there a
match for the mitigation funding also
there is a federal and non-federal share
it's typically a 75 federal 25
non-federal except now it's up to 90 10.
just for those two disasters from july
and august of 2021 that's correct i
thought mitigation funds were also
92. that's correct for the hazard
mitigation uh grant program but not the
other programs right fema runs
hazard mitigation is at 90 10.
just for these two just for the july
disasters not all are disasters i
thought it was mitiga i'm talking about
mitigation correct okay it's 75 25
except for these two disasters for
cheshire okay and if they apply for
mitigation funds than it will be at 90
so i think that this bill could
potentially impact all future funding
not just these two disasters that are
currently at a 90 10 cost share right so
in thinking long term okay yeah here's
my problem
okay i don't care how we word it
it doesn't matter to me i don't want to
mess somebody up
but
i want communities that have events
disaster events
okay
if they are going to get money
either in a
no-cost loan
or if we support 402
that they have to do something to
mitigate the problem
now
if you know
obviously if uh
if we have a snowstorm
you can get fema money for that but that
normally comes from the state
you know that's a
it's not an individual community
it's a right it's a statewide thing if
you have a
huge
so fema reimburses for snow disasters i
think you have to meet a certain
threshold of branches of snow and
provides money for that
i mean so you can't mitigate snow
you know so obviously to me
that doesn't fall into this category
because
if it's something that you can't
mitigate
then
you know you can't mitigate it but i i
just am
concerned that
i don't want
communities to think
that they can just
let things go
and come back five years from now
and
you know ask for the money again okay
so that would
be it would have to be some language to
say
you're going to rebuild to
it's not rebuilt tom it's mitigate
it's like
the reason that the flood occurred yeah
is because the river overflowed
okay i mean right
so the culverts and the bridges were not
able to handle the amount of rain they
came down
right
and so
the mitigation
maybe
because
i don't think fema will pay for
upgrading the uh
maybe they will upgrading the culverts
they will pay for it
that could be a mitigation but that but
that could be a mitigation project
to increase the size of the call for if
that's you know if that's what it takes
but fema doesn't on their disaster loans
i think
only puts it back to what it was
um so there are without going into too
nitty gritty detail there are two ways
that you can get mitigation funding from
fema one is through the disaster process
itself so fema public assistance
projects
um some of them have two parts to bring
it back to pre-disaster condition but
then what would it cost to mitigate it
to make the facility better so that's
all wrapped into public assistance then
there's the hazard mitigation grant
program hmgp which is a separate
so if some so with back to 409 so is
i have two questions
so the intent of 409 is not just for
sullivan and cheshire county it's for
all disasters moving forward okay so i
just needed to make sure that we're on
the same page there well obviously you
are but we want to make sure we're well
this bill was not just for so okay so
just want to make sure that we're she
and i are with you guys
representative sorry
um
so um
the next piece would be
i totally lost my train of thought i'm
it's
i think that paragraph is actually very
close to what we want to me it would be
something like the municipality shall
apply for available hazard mitigation
grant funding
the rest of that sentence is good
municipalities that do not apply for
such funding shall be in it
ineligible
and what it goes on to say i i think
it's exactly what we want
so i don't
both of these bills say and
and the municipality has applied for
emergency assistance they
they have to apply for it
already
so how about this
the municipality
should consider applying for available
hazard mitigation grant funding
okay
the municipality shall consider
applying for available hazard mitigation
grant funding that would reduce the
impact of future disasters for
facilities that were repaired using
so if they get a
no interest loan from the state
and they fix main street
they sh
shall consider applying for hazard
mitigation i don't think they should
consider it i think they need to
so the only thing there as vanessa was
saying there could be a cost to the
community to
but there's a cost to the state if they
don't
somebody's got to do the engineering
yeah so there's engineering work and
then there's the
match
i got it and is the state going to go to
402 is the state going to if 402 passes
pick up the
match i'll leave it at whether it's 25
or 10 because we don't know if we'll get
what match will get moving forward
is the state going to pick up the
mitigation match in addition to the
i'm sorry it's not easy it's not easy
we're making it more complex than it
already was no
i think that yeah go go ahead
thank you um i think we all are kind of
in agreement about the first shall apply
to all available hazard mitigation
grants and i i would be comfortable
adding as administered by fema since
there are grants perhaps in italy that
we don't know about
i was wondering for the second sentence
i hear the concern you have
and
i don't know logistically if this would
become a nightmare but municipalities
that do not seek funding may not be
eligible for future assistance loans
because there may be a good reason that
they don't apply
so is it a possibility to say they may
not be eligible and have that evaluated
at the time
given
circumstances uh which made it
oh okay so i i guess i'm a little bit
concerned about i mean if the
we're saying that
particularly particularly given the
circumstances that it may cost the
municipality
money
to make the application for the
mitigation grant so we're saying that
the municipality must choose to spend
the money
must choose to
expend money for that cost
as opposed to
you know suppose that suppose a minute
it's a poor municipality and they say
listen you know we have a we yeah we we
should do this but we also have a crime
problem and we need another police
officer so we decide it's more important
for us to get a police officer than
that are they that ineligible because
they made that decision yeah i'm not
sure that that really is fair to do
never mind fair
well
well i i mean i guess i i sort of think
that doing doing what's fair is
generally a good idea
well it's the question that you have to
ask yourself in my opinion
is
if a community does nothing to solve
their problem
[Music]
why should the state
solve their problem for them
okay you have to i agree you all we have
to make choices
okay we have to make choices
as a small community
or a large community i mean it doesn't
it doesn't matter
but you know um it doesn't say that you
have to apply for the
mitigation funds the day after the um
event
you know
so
if i could ask um the director
um
when you're approving the initial
emergency funding
what kind how much engineering do you
have to do
how do you tell them what to what
what the hell what shape to put it back
into it's it's very project dependent a
simple example would be a culvert often
requires something like a hydraulic
study to determine what size the new
culvert should be it could be something
like that so um so
that language could be incorporated with
the approval of the the emergency
funding
to say here's a range of
of the mitigation things that need to be
done and and at the top of the list
would be you know
i don't think i i
i don't think i mean that would be a way
for the for for that engineering to be
done without the town having to pay for
it after the separately
to pay for it out of the female money
well the female okay
can i make a suggestion
let's let
so i just wanted to
okay i just wanted to point out
that probably
one of the things that you might want to
require
is the town have a hazard mitigation
plan
because not every town has one
and
maybe what you want to be saying is that
they should have
a hazard mitigation plan
and that they should demonstrate how
or
i mean
but first you have to have a hazard
mitigation plan in hand
is required by by the state to have a
hazard mitigation pro plan sorry
so they do so every town has a hazard
mitigation plan that's approved by my
office as well as fema in boston
they have those plans because they
cannot get disaster funds without that
plan in place right they cannot get
they cannot receive hazard mitigation
funding without that so
right technically
a community could opt out and not have
that plan but it would be at an extreme
disadvantage and additionally this state
through fema fema provides funding for
these plans to be updated and we
coordinate that through our office
and the plans additionally outline
mitigation strategies that each
community comes up with and basically
those are their
priorities for funding so that might
be an option because they're already
defining where they think their issues
are within the community that need to be
addressed if funding becomes available
but we don't thank you judy but we don't
know if peop if the towns are doing
no
have a mitigation plan
if it's on the shelf and it's not making
any progress then it's going to be the
same it's going to be on the shelf not
making any progress i think we should
consider the use of the word consider as
you guys brought up and here's why the
municipality shall consider applying for
the available blah blah blah
because the second sentences say well
the first one says you must and then the
second one says if you don't so if you
put the shall consider it makes it
stronger but it still gives you the
option of not
but at your own peril if you don't apply
for it you're not getting any of this so
so
the municipality shall consider applying
for available hazard mitigation grant
funding administered by hsem
that would reduce the impact of future
disasters for facilities that were
repaired using exceptional disaster
i like that better then what bothers me
is the shell
do not seek funding shall be ineligible
for future assistance because you know
it's just too
that it's too capricious it's too wonder
if if somebody who's making the judgment
doesn't know all the facts
if
if someone can tell me why i why the
state should reward a community
for failure
to carry out their hazard mitigation
what about if we said and this is uh
it seems to me this gives a little more
room the municipality should apply to
all to all
should apply for we've got the first
paragraph all done
the municipality should apply for all
available hazard mitigation grant
funding available to reduce the impact
of a disaster reoccurrence
the governor and council and the fiscal
committee may consider whether a
municipality has such such funding in
considering whether to grant a loan
under paragraph 2a in other words that
what that says is it's a factor the
governor and council can consider they
might say you know women you work this
municipality was just completely you
know irresponsible and that's and we're
not there they don't get another one but
in in circumstance a but maybe there's
another circumstance in which
the governor and council and the fiscal
committee say all right
you know this is not this is not uh the
municipality didn't act irresponsibly in
these circumstances and therefore they
can get the loan i did you know was it
like it allows it to it's not a hard and
fast rule it's let the let the people at
the time make the decision as to whether
the municipality acted irresponsibly and
not in not getting the
the uh
the
uh the loan
not applying for the mitigation funding
and all the people in the town suffer
okay so lynn what did you say
i think whatever we do we just have to
the
the municipality shall consider applying
for available hazard mitigation grant
funding administered by hsem
that would reduce the impact of future
disasters for facilities that were
repaired using exceptional disaster
relief loan funding that's perfect can
you keep the second sentence just as it
is
municipalities that do not apply for or
seek or whatever you want
funding shall be
guys i have two questions
um go ahead
municipalities that do not seek
um
what constitutes seeking i guess i would
have one question on that and they might
not get it you know they may try they
and the other thing is that because it
i can just imagine
i you know i i can't imagine some of the
consequences that might come from it so
i still would be more comfortable with
municipalities that do not see sex
funding may not be eligible
and have the opportunity for them to
explain why they didn't apropos
representative lynn if they needed to
hire a policeman which is probably
not going to happen
but just to give a little bit of space
um for something that we can't
anticipate here i certainly agree with
the intent of this that they really
bloody well ought to be doing the best
mitigation they can
but there may be a situation where it's
not possible or you know something else
happens so i kind of like a little bit
go ahead
so
we were just talking about the word seek
as well because you
we use the word shell in the first
sentence and then we use the word seek
in the second sentence
um
but then there's
do you want to go sure just a fact to
consider is that fema's mitigation
programs are fairly limited there's kind
of a short list of types of projects
that they will accept so using the
example we've been running with main
street for example they may use an
exceptional disaster relief loan to
repair that facility and then turn
around and seek mitigation funding only
to find there are no viable options that
fema mitigation will fund just because
of the type of facility
in which case they could submit an
application and they know from the
beginning that it will not be eligible
so historically and vanessa can add more
details but 60 thousand foot
historically we've worked with
communities that have put in for
mitigation projects
that we try for a number of years
different ways to get them funding
and
the process
has not allowed us to be successful many
times
so they go through lots of expense lots
of time actually a couple years with a
couple of towns
to come back to say yep sorry no there's
it's not allowable but the way it's
worded it doesn't say
i shall apply and receive it just says
you shall apply so if they apply and
then they're not given that
money that second sentence becomes
meaningless
and i think
the use of the word seek in the second
sentence
are we are we exchanging that
okay i was i was going to say seek does
provide flexibility to the community to
reach out to our agency and have a
conversation about the viability of a
project before spending money so they're
still exploring the opportunity without
potentially incurring the expense of
engineering costs etc we can give a
community a pretty good idea of how
viable a project might be before they
ever have to take money out of their
bank account to pay for it so i think
seek would provide that flexibility
potentially but the word apply
may not
right
good point
so can i just make one other this is
this is why i'm not sure i like these
things
to the extent yes to the extent the
concern was you know if you like if you
leave this discretionary
it's going to become political i mean i
would remind you that in paragraph 2a
this is it's described the governor that
says the governor may with the approval
may approve this isn't the required
thing the governor the governor has
discretion and so does the fiscal
committee and the guy the council so
it's you know to the extent that makes
can i just down a point so we hse so we
had to create a rule
when the exceptional disaster relief
loan bill was first introduced by
senator gaida after the flooding up in
grafton county
we had to create a rule about how the
exceptional disaster relief
fund is administered through my office
one page application
i'll throw myself under the bus
we
could within the rule
address
the second piece of this within the rule
potentially potentially
um
yep
so if this passes we have to go to jail
par anyways to change it to meet the
no interest and the governor declares a
state of emergency so we have to change
the ruling
likely that we'll have to change the
rule
no we're not
we're not
i say you go with your rewritten first
sentence and just leave the second
sentence alone
right
that gives you your seek
still gets the it still mandates or
still
basically says what i think rip umberger
is getting at and that's what i would
agree on that if you're not making any
effort to mitigate you're not going to
get paid
funds in the future it says shall be out
ineligible
right
that's right and that's that's what it's
supposed to be
if they don't seek
available hazard mitigation they shall
not they shall be ineligible that's i
think that's the whole intent
but can't you envision a situation where
it wouldn't be their fault and you're
penalizing them beyond something that
they couldn't control and so i'm just
asking a little bit but what i don't
know about logistically who all's going
to make that decision but it seems
just prudent to have a little bit of
wiggle room for what we cannot
anticipate here
yeah i mean what so what are you gonna
what are you gonna do if they don't
do you gotta
if then if what are you gonna do if they
don't do that and they get wiped out
again
yeah oh well oh well
i can't how long's all the well last and
the roads and you can't float down you
can't get any emergency vehicles or
i don't i don't mean i'm not going to
support the second sentence here
i have to say i think i think it's too
harsh also so what do you want to put in
there you want me to use the term may
just be happy
well just just the first sentence that
says you shall um apply for the
hazard mitigation although
it sounds like they already are getting
advice on that
through fema
well they may or may not
i mean i don't know when the last time
this flood in
sullivan and cheshire county took place
do you know this july 2021
before that before that
it's as far as a declared disaster goes
it's been a while but there are many
instances of flooding that don't rise to
the level of a federal declaration it
but we don't know when those were
our office doesn't track that doesn't
track them
all right
can can i
can i get
my hard-line friends like me to
six
um funding may not be eligible or maybe
ineligible i like may not be eligible i
support the the the idea i think it's a
really good idea i think you ought to do
mitigation i'm just thinking god there
might be that situation where it doesn't
work
but um that they may not be eligible for
future assistance and to me that kind of
gets their if i can say this but that's
their attention you guess their things
that's better than button gear yeah that
gets their attention and there are
consequences and i think you know the
consequences are real they should be
there should be consequences i just like
a little
teensy weensy little pillow and
municipalities do sometimes i mean they
have contracts they have to pay
sometimes there are emergencies that
come up that they better take care of
first
so we're going to say in the i mean if
this if
this i mean let me just say this okay
by the time they get their fema money
they get the work done
they get their
you know
fema doesn't
work very quickly
and it could be four or five years
i mean it's not like
it's not like it's gonna happen tomorrow
but during that time
in my opinion
they should be planning for how they're
going to mitigate this from happening
again
that's fine i don't care maybe not so if
you leave if so if you but if you leave
shell in the first sentence right that
says that's the command you shall do
this and all i think i think all all uh
representative murray is saying and i
agree with her on this is if you if you
change shell to may on line six then you
are giving you've told them you have to
do this but in the in the sort of
penalty provision you've said
and if you don't we may not give it to
you we're not saying for sure we won't
but we may not
may may on the seconds
may not be um
may not be eligible i think is
clearer to understand if you put may
rather than shall who's going to make
i guess that was my concern of logistics
here but in the rest of the the bill
you've got the governor and approved the
executive council and that seems to be
built into the
other part of the bill
yep because they may or may not get that
from the executive council
and the governor
right and they could contain and the
governor and council and the fiscal
committee could all consider
so the fact that they haven't they
didn't do that yeah fiscal committee
doesn't need to be in on that okay all
right
and they can make a recommendation they
make a recommendation to the governor
and council
because i think there's got to be
somebody who knows really what they do
don't have my michael
somebody else has to approve it anyway
somebody's got to approve it
it's usually them isn't it
i mean the municipality applies for it
may can contribute something and then
femur is going to be the final approval
but to that point it ought to be pretty
obvious whether or not they've done any
work you know i'm not sure it takes an
engineer to say that you know oh you've
just not done anything and we're not
going to give you more money you know
these are
this is bricks and mortar yeah it is
and they've been working together okay
no
so chris you have all this down
so that you can uh
create a new amendment for us
so i'd like you to go through it one
more time so that we have all the
language correct because it's been
pretty much all over the map
so the first sentence if i could just
have somebody go through what's agreed
to with that
he may consider
shall consider jennifer will read that
so
what we had was the municipality shall
consider applying for available hazard
mitigation grant funding administered by
hsem
that would reduce the impact of future
disasters for facilities that were
repaired using exceptional disaster
[Music]
reduce the impact of future disasters
for facilities that were repaired
using exceptional disaster relief loan
funding
and then in the second sentence all you
were changing was funding may not be
eligible on line six so you are striking
yeah funding may not be eligible
can i also
seek
it's not
i don't think it does to completely
defeat it what it's simply because it
says to whoever's going to make this
decision the governor and council that
this is a factor if you haven't that you
know that they they could say they could
say in any particular case we're not
awarding this we're not going to award
this loan because you didn't
you didn't do this and then you're back
to a political decision
it's two different activities it's
that makes sense to me because i mean if
those things if we're saying those
things are important
that people should be updating them
and this is going to be tied to
something you need to turn on your mic i
know but
otherwise people can't hear you i just
feel if we're going to make this
high risk
because if they're not applying it
becomes high risk
because they will not get money
in the future
um by being able to demonstrate progress
they have made toward meeting the
goals or areas cited in their hazard
mitigation plan i mean that would be
whether they're showing progress or not
i just i just hate to have a place
that's gone through a horrible disaster
to all of a sudden
be told well sorry but you didn't apply
for these grants so you can't get any
money again i mean god forbid the same
place should have the same kind of a
disaster three or four times
and
that area that's what i'm trying to
prevent
okay because obviously
we haven't done a good job of that but
some some natural disasters aren't
always avoidable
and i mean some things you can't always
fix
suggestion what about if you had just
one sentence that said something like
this
municipality
that has
already received
a
a non-interest loan under subsection a
shall not be eligible for another loan
for the same for a dessert for a
disaster in the same area unless it
demonstrates that it has made
substantial progress on a disaster
mitigation
uh program or however you want to seize
it i mean is that that that doesn't set
says that they have to they have to have
made progress and that you know
um
i think maybe we can do fewer words i
can see where you're going
municipalities must demonstrate progress
on their mitigation plan or they will
that's fine with me
[Laughter]
define progress or substantial progress
well again i guess um apropos we had
said before um this is bricks and mortar
it was the road under construction do
they have
do they have a contract with the road
builder so i think
so that's not what mitigation is all
about
that's that's the actual disaster
the mitigation is fixing the culvert on
the side road to divert the water from
downtown
we're moving the road that was down at
river level
well they may not be but
right but i mean the other thing i i
think representative uh uh is
correct on this i mean suppose suppose
that there are several problems in a
town
and what they've done
is after the first loan
they've developed a sort of you know
capital improvement program or whatever
you want to you ever want to call it to
deal with areas in the town where are
they are susceptible to flooding but the
ones that they decided to work on first
were
something other than this particular
area i mean how would we then say well
because you chose to fix you know elm
street as a as opposed to main street
you're not going to be eligible for
another loan i i would tend to say
maybe if there's some you know if that
in a particular case was a really
unreasonable decision but maybe it isn't
a unreasonable decision all right so if
i'm understanding this correctly
if
kate could you repeat witches
or was it murray could you repeat right
municipalities must demonstrate progress
on their mitigation plan
in order to be eligible for
future assistance or future loans under
whatever the rest of it
municipalities must be a must they must
demonstrate progress
on their mitigation plan
but there's some words missing there
um i just wanted to also provide a
little bit more context for the local
hazard mitigation plans so each plan is
required to
put into their local hazard mitigation
plan
mitigation strategies for high risk
hazards that they identify so for
example majority if not all of our
communities identify flooding as a high
risk because it's statewide
there are typically 15 to 30 mitigation
strategies that any one community can
put into their plan there's no federal
requirement that they attack all of
these at any one given time is just
supposed to be a priority for funding
opportunities so when you say make
progress on their hazard mitigation plan
i am confirming are you looking for them
to make progress on their identified
mitigation strategies within their plan
now i think we're looking for strategies
on the ground actual projects that are
undergoing sorry let me clarify those 15
to 30 mitigation strategies typically
include
facilities on the ground as well but
they might also include planning efforts
in addition to that but for example
it's likely that they're identifying
facilities that are undersized like
culverts or bridges that are in
disrepair
etc i'm
uh i understand the planning is
important i think i'm leaning towards
and i think we all some of us other here
are leaning towards actual work being
done beyond the planning
so
so municipalities must demonstrate
implement
implementation
are we trying to make this apply though
to it the town's mitigation plan or
ruined in the previous
uh event such as in acworth i i think
that's the intent of this it's
we know this happened here what are you
doing to fix you're going to apply
to fix this
and if you don't it happens again
because it talks about that area or that
specific
so one of the words that causes us just
whatever is the word location because we
didn't know if that meant
i.e the town of vanessa
or main street in the town of vanessa
is the locat when you say location do
you mean the entire community or do you
mean the facility our word facility that
we use in that first sentence
means a road a bridge a culvert
okay
but
i can agree
two municipalities
must demonstrate progress
on implementation
within that no it would be the facility
main street in vanessa town
not the mitigation plan because you all
said that's a town wide
on one thing right
could there be a situation though where
you know this bridge was washed away so
they've repaired the bridge with their
emergency and
you know there's a wide range of
mitigation possibilities and this bridge
is going to be okay for another seven
years but this one's gonna only last two
weeks if they're working on this bridge
it's gonna go down in two weeks i'd be
okay with that
with regards to this i wouldn't think
let's you know not let's ignore this
bridge and get this one in order to get
this funds i just assumed they fixed the
other bridge too
so in that sense it wouldn't necessarily
be
i think the intent
is that you're making attempts
that was caused in the last
event
that's the way i understand it and
that's
as an example like the example i gave is
every 10 years the mississippi and the
missouri river flood
and the fema and the feds go in and give
people all kinds of money and ever
another 10 years the exact same thing
happens over and over and over
this what we want to do is fix that
scenario so the culvert under the bridge
in acworth it was too small when you put
it back it needs to be bigger
i think that's what we're getting so
that i think you're using the word
facility it's not the town's plan but
i think that's what you read the first
time so
so if you say municipalities
must demonstrate progress on the
implementation
municipalities must demonstrate progress
on the implementation of their hazard
mitigation plan
in order to be eligible for future
assistance
under this section
for disasters affecting facilities
i hope somebody got it because i was
you had the magic words and it wasn't
recorded
ah come on chris
did you get them on the phone and ask
them
how about this municipalities must
demonstrate progress
on the
implementation of their hazard
in order to be
eligible for future assistance and then
continue
the rest of your
um
amendment in the second sentence where
it says for future assistance blah blah
did we get that do you need me one more
municipalities must demonstrate progress
on the implementation
of their
hazard mitigation plan
in order to
be eligible
for future assistance loans under this
section for disasters affecting
facilities
where an exceptional disaster relief
loan was previously granted
okay
does somebody have that exact language
uh so chris we'll have to um
why do we even need it
why don't we um
why don't we combine these two
into one
burger into one amendment yeah yep
i mean
that
okay
and that will replace that replace all
all of 402
no
we're just
yeah we'll have an amendment yeah but
it's combining these two pieces of paper
into one
with the changes that we made that makes
okay so represent home burger is the
intention that the committee's gonna the
division's gonna come back to look at
this amendment one more time before it
goes to the executive yeah we're gonna
have to okay
okay
uh
yes
we're not going back to the other one
what do we need them both
well can we look at 402
but then 402
um
what it's doing relative to financial
assistance for municipalities affected
by the disaster and this is giving
authority to the governor isn't
this the same thing
oh that
um
yes
mickey gave us this title one
i feel like we're we're just kind of
repeating ourselves
yeah
or
creating another bill on top of what we
which is probably not necessary no
where do i have that i know i have it
i know i know
it's uh
9 13 d
yeah
so upset umberger if i might um i think
the difference might be 402 requires
that doesn't require a civil emergency
be declared and that's the difference
between what mickey provided you
um okay in the language
yeah
this gives the governor authority to
take necessary steps
in the event that there hasn't been
an emergency declaration
and specific
it's been a long time since i've been in
especially i don't think you've ever
been in two
i didn't think so
that's because we have so much fun that
uh
i don't know
okay i don't know that we need um they
they are different the major difference
and i'm opposed to this one i i don't
think we need it also but the main
difference is
this is a grant the other one's alone i
mean when you
get right down to it that's the major
difference one's like one's a grant
one's alone and i'm personally not in
favor of a all-out grant
i i wasn't so
40409 that we just did was a
non-interest loan
this one here is just general funds that
the governor can disperse
as it doesn't say anything about paying
it back
representative murray
can someone i think i have this right
now but can i we just confirm this when
i read this
um you know the governor with approval
fiscal no no may approve disbursements
of financial assistance to affected
communities when i was first reading
this my understanding was that it was
pertaining to the
amount that the state of the
municipality has to pay back to fema
that you know let's just say the 90
percent you know the 10 percent that has
to get paid back but the way this is
written and what i'm hearing now is that
the governor could potentially give you
know 300 million dollars to some little
town that had a disaster there's nothing
here that focuses it on that 10 so am i
misreading this or did this get changed
significantly and i'm uncomfortable with
if i'm if i might this is i think you're
reading i think the way you're reading
it is exactly right i mean that could
happen that's not maybe what was
intended but that's what the language
says
this this language is from
an amendment by senator mawson in uh
march 29th
and it's
brought it's just a just a wide open so
yes go ahead so
that was one of the questions that so i
have a little list of things that
you know this is open-ended
representative it doesn't
say july 2021 flooding
so i wasn't sure if the intent was to
have this bill in place for every
disaster moving forward
it doesn't talk about the match
which
could be
25 or 10 percent
so i think
right this is the first time i've been
here for 30 years
and it's the first time that i've seen a
10 match it's always been 25
and then there was the time that the
state picked up the
so it is a it is a grant but if you want
to put the word match in there
use the word match but don't put a
percentage in case we get another 10
percent but we might not get
but in senator khan's testimony he
talked about that
so he inferred it but it's not written
in the text
so if it's not the text
the other thing this doesn't talk about
mitigation efforts either when you give
a grant there's going to be less of a
impetus for the community to
work on their mitigation efforts on the
on the whatever the issue was if you're
just being granted the money
with no
no requirement to pay it back like a
loan would do
the mitigation part may might not be so
important to the time
so
i could i just make a comment
certainly if we i it it seemed to me
that that the main
purpose of of this whole area of having
some uh
state have some ability to provide funds
was to be able if i understood
uh
uh the representative aaron's 409 and if
even if 402 was limited and i think it
would have to be because for the reasons
that representative murray stated but
even if it was limited to simply
you know what happens
to the can the state sort of forgive
um
uh
some of the money that
some of the uh
the
money that isn't the money for a
disbursement that's not that that's made
under 409 that is not covered by the
federal reimbursement can the state
forgive
some part of that loan if even if 402
was limited to that purpose that's not
something that's going to happen right
away it's going to you're talking about
something that happens way after the
fact a year or two later so
i guess my suggestion is
why don't we do this sort of
incrementally 409 let's do 409 and sort
of
see how it you know how it how it works
for over a few years and then uh if
there if that turns out to be not
satisfactory and the legislature needs
to do something else we'll have some
experience with how 409 has worked and
now my understanding
based on
the testimony
was that
402 would come into play
when
the fema has already identified
eligibility
um they've determined
100 of the funds that would be eligible
and 402 would be directed toward
that ten percent of the funds
that
they don't pay because it's 90 10 or 75
25 whatever
and so if the state so chill chose
they could make
a grant
to a municipality
that's it
so that's
that's what we think the intent is
as well as you you
[Music]
projects on their own
then
this would help them do that
no
that's not that's not what this says
what this says is
when it comes time to pay fema the 25
then you can request this grant
you've already laid out all your money
yeah
you know i don't care what percent
okay
my clarification was just regarding the
fema process um
that you don't have to pay fema money
for the 25
the town
expenses the full 100 and fema just
reimburses whatever percentage is
applicable to that disaster right right
i uh yeah i'm sorry i got that i know i
know that so 402 is the after the fact
so fema's paid the
90 or 75 whatever and then a community
can ask
the state
for
and then
the state makes a determination whether
they want to
provide a community that grant or not
oops the community's already paid the
money
they've done the work they've been
reimbursed 90
so we fixed a bridge we got paid 900
thousand dollars
there's a hundred thousand dollars that
was the the
piece that fema was not paying we want
to come to the state and say hey but
they've already expensed it
correct what they're asking for they're
asking the state to give them a grant so
that they become whole reimburse some of
it
this is where i think the mitigation
goes
no no
you know i'm fine with them you know
with this
as the match this is just way open-ended
this is goes way beyond so i don't even
can't even i don't even know why this is
here um
i'm comfortable with the match and i'm
can go either way if it's a grant or if
it's a loan but
i think especially when you're having
small communities that are suffering you
know quite a dreadful tragedy or a
disaster that they can come to the state
to ask for help um you know 50 you know
to fill in that the 10 or 25 whatever it
is so i like that idea i don't like how
this has been expanded to um to pretty
much everything it seems
just so can i ask can i just
raise a question by sort of an example
so
let's if i'm understanding correctly
what what 402 is designed to to
address is this situation let's say that
the that municipality suffers a disaster
and just you know making a number up it
it's going to cost a million dollars to
refi to uh
to fix it so the municipality applies to
fema and they say yep you're you know
i'm sorry the municipality
applies for a loan under 409
for a million dollars from the from the
state and in anticipation of getting
getting money from fema and the state
gives the municipality a million dollars
now the municipality applies to fema
fema says yes you're qualified we're
going to give you let's assume it's a 90
10 we're going to give you 900 000
so they have nine hundred thousand
dollars now the municipality uses that
nine hundred thousand dollars to repay
nine hundred thousand dollars of the
loan but they still owe another hundred
thousand
and if i understand what 402 is designed
to accomplish it's designed to say
that in effect
the govern the the feds i mean the the
state can forgive some or all of that
other hundred thousand is that basically
what
is happening
by turning it in from old by turning it
from a loan into a grant that's one such
scenario i guess in order for a
community to utilize 402 they don't
technically have to have a loan from the
state so they could have just expended
the amount out of pocket and then come
to the state and say we need assistance
so two different potential scenarios
yes uh from someone we've not heard from
not much
right uh is there anything in law right
now that has a forgiveness feature like
all step that was the 25 match that the
state picked up no that was wasn't that
90 was that the 90 10 no to the south
this july this past july is the 9010.
is there anything in law that says that
uh
there's no law right now for anything
for matchmaking no no forgiveness in
other words you you owe the 25
the original bill
was the
match match only
that the state would pick up half of the
match
so
when we first got it it was 25 so the
original bill was to be like
12 and a half percent this town would
pay 12 and a half percent the state
would pay and it's morphed
also on these mitigation plans how
how well do these towns
follow through with their mitigation
plans
it varies in in follow through you mean
well they they do so i mean they make
progress right they address some of the
issues that the plan identified it
varies and i think a lot of it has to do
with how much funding the town actually
has to accomplish those goals because
some things might be simple like
you know a small culvert to a slightly
larger culvert some issues might include
a large bridge
it depends
what the town's need is and what their
assets are to put towards that their
capital improvement projects
okay
um
do we need to think about this or
do we
uh because we're gonna have to come back
on the other one anyhow
could we get a copy of the original bill
before it was amended to be so
open-ended
yeah
it's uh
if you go to the legislative website and
go to the bill search
and you go to the doctor i don't why
don't you just do that and have janet
bring it to us
okay
i've never been able to go backwards on
well we'll have janet run it
because i had to have a lesson in how to
do that
it's listed it's listed as
introduced or amended so janet will
janet will run that off for us
um
so i guess that
what i would suggest is that we will um
um hearing on both bills
you're going to re retest recess
oh recessions when do you have when do
yeah
these bills have are um they have to be
done by the 28th
but i'm going to hold some sort of a
executive session
um
before then to clear up the ones that
that we can
and um
then
whatever
i guess we're these are the only two we
yeah no i'm talking about that are due
the 28th
these are the only ones we have
so um
[Music]
next
and reps of home burger i think it's 4
26 is your exact session
oh don't don't pay any attention to what
that said okay i'll ignore that thank
you
yeah that's fine why don't you come up
and uh
then
well good afternoon and thank you for
inviting me by the way you don't have to
sit back there so shy
no not in not in division two well thank
you very much okay i appreciate that but
i wasn't going to make any comments as
we had supported both pieces of
legislation they seem to be companion
pieces of legislation however both doing
something very different one providing
the grant type funds and one of course
ensuring that
communities can apply for the loan
situation
we are not fema experts
we certainly leave that to fema to come
into our communities we know that towns
develop hazardous mitigation plans
however
in many cases
it's the unforeseen especially that
first time around that unforeseen
situation that tends to occur
it's somewhat like the pandemic we all
planned and had those plans and um they
didn't work
and
i think the language you're proposing
seems reasonable
as long as it
still allows a municipality some grace
should there be some extenuating
circumstance that is unforeseen and that
we couldn't consider
on sb 409 and of course we support sb
402 so we would not like to see that
bill
bitl
because there could be a situation in
um
this is
don't don't move this could be to the
committee as well but could we put some
the size of the community you know you
have a little town yeah but
little towns don't i mean in this
particular case it doesn't matter it's a
disaster that makes a difference
so
well wasn't it that it was going to be
hard to predict what a disaster costs
i guess the percentage is the best we
came because if you're looking for
to try to make it equitable for a larger
community as opposed to a smaller
community i mean the larger communities
are going to have greater resources they
have a tax base that's larger than a
town of 900. um
i guess i would like just to see it go
back to the match and not be
i i tend to agree but in a city like
mine
um and i use my tornado
some horrible event that wipes out half
our city
um or even a portion of our city i mean
that would be millions and millions of
dollars
to
to address
and would
we have reserves but we don't have those
i think
i think we're getting distracted here by
by including the grants and the and the
percentages and all that i don't think
there's any of that in here i think this
this language just gives the governor
authority to act right away
right well it's open-ended i mean it's
but that's what it's that's what it is
that was one of the things that why we
got to this version of 402 was because
in the original version
somebody asked
well how much do we budget and i was
somebody this morning how we're you know
working on the 24-25 budget how much do
you put it into budgets and i said i
can't project that because i don't know
what the disaster and costs are going to
be
yeah i i understand that and i'm saying
and even in even in the hearing senator
morsi ex
asked how much
how much
is the total
and he was looking for
total money but this is his amendment
and he meant he amended the whole bill
to just say well just give the governor
the authority to act quickly
and then the funds have to be available
to do so well well if you appropriate
them in the budget they're there i mean
it's just going to draw no no but not
now but that's the amount to put in i
mean what do you put in you don't put it
in the budget or it could be surplus i
mean a trust
nope
because that was tried this morning
right there's nothing in here that says
the state pays anything
you know there's the option of helping
out the communities or at least going
back to the match of saying well you
know the state will put in 5 000 and
we'll cover your 5 000 too but there's
really nothing here that requires the
state to actually do anything
so i guess i i i have a question and i'm
not sure that i still understand this
and maybe the people from from
you maybe you can explain it to us to me
supposed under the under 402 is it's
worded right now
if there was a disaster
and they and you know you
it was it was declared by the governor
or the or for the president declared
whatever
if if the governor decided with the all
the appropriate approvals to make a
grant
right at the beginning to a municipality
to pay some or all of the expenses of
the disaster
would
if i'm understanding correctly then you
correct me if i'm wrong fema would say
well wait a minute you've gotten this
money whatever it is five you've gotten
five hundred thousand dollars as a grant
from the state
so
that five hundred thousand dollars is
now is you've got another source for
that it's no longer eligible is that
right
um
that was part of the discussion in the
session this morning actually um
regarding potential duplication of
benefits and so i think that one of the
recommendations that came out of that
meeting was
putting something in here with language
specifying that this money would only be
used for
non-federal match which is not
reimbursable by the federal government
um
and then potentially things that are not
eligible under fema's public assistance
program are eligible for federal funding
in general so because this bill changed
from the original
one that was introduced to the amended
one
the types of things that could be funded
also changed originally it was just the
match for these two disasters and then
it looks like it has changed to
potentially include match for any
disasters moving forward or in the past
and also things that are not fema
eligible so the option is i guess to
determine what is the goal of the bill
and then
from there shift the language to achieve
that goal
right so in other words
i this really
sort of goes along with what
representative murray was saying earlier
we
we can't pass this bill
just the way it is because it's not
limited to either a match or
non-eligible
it's for anything so
we need i mean unless if we don't do if
we didn't make those kind of changes
we would there would be
we would there would be running a risk
that by having this law there's some
the
fema would say it's not
the money is not of the the money
it's duplication of you have sort of
money from another source
correct there could be a potential
duplication of benefits however if it
were structured to include language such
as
this funding may only be used for
non-federal match for disasters then we
if representative murray thank you if i
may representative walt's passed me
language in this
to add to the end of line eight i'm just
going to start reading from the previous
line
the general court and executive council
may approve disbursements of financial
assistance to affected municipalities to
the extent they are not eligible for
fema benefits or the municipalities part
we're reading that you mean that one
more time
okay
assistant yeah assistance to the
affected municipalities to the extent
they are not eligible for fema benefits
or the municipalities part of the fema
match
we were reading that uh representative
wall street
she pulled it right out of the sky i can
just do this and i'm not even a lawyer
it just comes to me like a ouija board
[Laughter]
oh you didn't you didn't print it out
over here
that's that's the next uh the next on
the learning curve okay
well
all right
um
give that to chris for
an amendment
um
i'm still not sure that
i like this bill at all
um but um
we're gonna have to we're gonna have to
get together anyhow can't we just make
one bill and and i mean this does have
potential i think the the uh possibility
let me just say i don't want to end one
bill because i can support the other but
not this
okay that way
i don't want to be in a situation where
i can't support
so
okay
so you'll give that to chris
we'll get an amendment
um
next
okay i was going to recess this
is anybody going to be here around
tomorrow
is that too soon
thursday
yeah
no i meant a time um
okay friday we've got fiscal committee
you've got the funeral we don't want to
discuss these after the funeral
um
so
can you hang on just one second let me
go check janet's calendar
i think you saw the problem that we had
originally
which is get money to the towns to fix
the problem
yeah alone and that's it that's what
i mean well this other bill is
grant it's a grant
yeah
and and grants are
money because you got to take money from
the treasury yeah the treasury it comes
federal funds no
oh general yeah you still got to take it
well if you want to pitch in hey you can
write a check
well because because the old days you
had to whine and watch yes and left
handers have to
that's a left-handed watch or what i
guess so
you're kidding me
is that good really
okay
um
do we want to do
the 18th appears that i don't
we haven't gotten anything scheduled
there
yeah yeah as long as we do it
before
it will be done by four o'clock or by 3
30. oh yeah
yeah
um
you want to say 10 does that work or
would you rather have
one
okay
well yeah let's try to try to
subcommitted so it's fun
we'll be here you'll be here
yeah does that work
len
llenn may be enjoying his uh day in rome
or something
or paris or
okay anyhow well we'll plan on 10
o'clock on the 18th and it seems to me
that i've got something going on on the
18th
that
yeah let's do the 19th instead of the
18th
no
we got we got two travelers we got to
travel yeah tom and i have a hard time
no work
we don't we just do work sessions here
we vote but all we do is take our vote
to the uh
main committee
okay
no
oh yeah yeah
okay
so i i think we've got 409
settled
and it's just what we decide to do with
402.
okay
boy mickey is so happy he wasn't here
today
i don't know he's someplace
um
right
okay thank you chris you have done a
marvelous job you haven't got the
amendments back yet
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah okay
that's that's uh you've done a wonderful
okay
you